- Hey, hey, welcome, welcome, welcome in
to another exciting, spellbinding,
action-packed edition
of "Market Takes."
We have a just absolutely
packed week of data for you
coming out this week, but
I am going to tell you
the three most important things
that you need to be
watching out for this week.
I am Dion Rabouin, reporter
at "The Wall Street Journal."
This is "Market Takes."
I know you could have been
anywhere in the world,
but you're here with me
and I appreciate that.
Listen, this week, like I
said, we've got a lot coming
but the first thing you're
gonna wanna watch this week
we get the US retail sales report.
I'm gonna tell you why that's gonna be
so important this week.
Next we get three major reports
on the US housing market.
I'm gonna tell you what
all three of those are,
what to look for in those.
And then we get some earnings reports
from big name retailers,
Home Depot, Walmart,
and Target all coming out this week.
So we are going to hear a
lot about the US consumer,
the health of the US consumer,
and that's gonna tell us
about the US economy, spending,
all of those things because, as you know,
those are what really
drive the US economy.
So let's get into it.
First things first, let's talk
about the US retail sales report
that is gonna be out on Tuesday for April.
I wanna put this up here
on your screen right now.
Just give you an idea
what we're talking about.
Now, as you look over there on the right,
when we get into 2023 and
those months leading into 2023,
you see there that we have
negative month-over-month numbers.
So in November, December,
you saw retail sales were negative.
Then January we got a
big pickup up, about 3%.
And then in February and March
we have seen a decline again
on those retail sales numbers.
So that's showing us right now
that we've got a worrisome trajectory.
We're seeing a consistent
theme and a consistent pattern.
As inflation has been falling
along with expectations,
we are also seeing those
retail sales numbers.
Again, those aren't pulled
out, those aren't real numbers.
Those are basically
not inflation adjusted.
So we are seeing overall
retail sales declining
month over month for the last five months.
And if we get another decline in April,
that'll be five out of
the last six months.
We have seen, again, that
last month was down 1%
after 0.2% negative the month before.
Economists are projecting
that we are going to get
a 0.8% increase in April.
And so that would sort of
buck this trend we've seen.
But, as you'll see there on your screen,
consistently we've been negative
for the last five months.
I wanna put another chart
up here on your screen
to just show you what this
looks like year over year.
And as you can see, just
a consistent decline.
Ever since we hit that 10% number in July,
retail sales have been coming
down, coming in each month.
Year over year We're
seeing a declining trend.
And so we're seeing that
both month over month
and year over year and
that just illustrating
the overall trend and trajectory
of retail sales, as in declining spending.
Spending is pulling back,
consumers not buying as much,
really getting some of
that inflation fatigue
even as inflation has been coming down.
And we are also seeing
that combined with another
kind of worrisome trend.
I wanna put another chart
up here on your screen here.
And this is the US initial jobless claims.
This is the number of people filing
for unemployment claims or
saying, okay, I've lost my job.
I need to get on unemployment,
requesting for the government
aid in that sector.
And as you see, in 2023, the
numbers had been going down
but we are seeing a pickup.
And last week we saw
initial jobless claims
at the highest since October 2021.
So the numbers still low broadly.
Overall, we're seeing
still lower than average
or lower than typical numbers
on those initial jobless claims.
But the trajectory, we're
seeing a pickup of the trend
and, like I said, the highest
in almost two years last week.
So still low but that
trajectory could be worrisome.
And that's just, that chart
on your screen right there
is illustrating what we're seeing
in the initial jobless claims market
in the unemployment market
that could be worrisome.
So last thing, let's talk about housing.
Housing, AKA shelter,
was the biggest component
of core CPI inflation,
which picked up more
than expected last month.
We saw, and we have seen consistently
over the last few months,
housing has been a major piece
of the overall inflation picture.
And this week we'll
get three more reports.
So we get the NAHB housing market index,
that's out on Tuesday.
Then we will get housing
starts, that's out on Wednesday.
And then the big kahuna,
existing home sales on Thursday.
I wanna put a chart up here on your screen
to show you what we're
seeing in existing home sales
and why maybe this could be worrisome.
And you see a clear pickup
in the home or the median sales price,
as in the average price
for an existing home.
You're seeing a pickup there.
And that's really what
we've seen all year is
housing is starting to pick
back up in terms of price.
That chart just illustrating
a very clear short term
but a very clear trend of housing prices
starting to get more expensive.
We have seen that start to rise again
after that long-term
decrease that you saw also.
March marked the first
yearly rent price decrease
in 36 months, according to rent.com.
And it followed six consecutive months
of single-digit increases,
which means we were seeing
a consistent downturn in
terms of price increases.
However, we are seeing monthly
rental rates increase 5.3%
in the last week of March,
according to that same survey.
So again this is just showing us
the trend is picking back up.
And we know and we have seen consistently,
going back for most of about a year now,
shelter or housing is a big piece
of that overall inflation picture.
And we are seeing housing
prices start to pick back up.
That is despite a 75%
increase in inventory,
as in more homes being built,
we are seeing more inventory
on the shelf, but (laughs) or
more inventory on the shelf.
We're seeing more inventory in
the market as in more houses
but that's not bringing the the price down
because demand is still so high.
So you'll wanna watch out
for each of those reports
with the big one being existing
home sales on Thursday.
Last but not least, we get
Walmart, Target, and Home Depot
earnings all out this week.
Home Depot will kick
things off on Tuesday.
That's big because of
what we just talked about,
those prices for existing home sales.
And we are seeing a consistent
increase in home builders.
Those home builder stocks
have really just been shooting
up the charts, seeing big gains
for home building companies.
But is that translating
to the real economy?
Is that making more jobs for folks?
Are folks going out and buying
things to furnish these homes
or is that just an investment boom?
Is that just folks, you
know, who are delivering
what was already promised?
We will learn a lot about that
in those Home Depot earnings
that we get on Tuesday and
that's gonna tell us a lot.
Thursday we hear from Walmart,
that is the biggest retailer in the US.
That's gonna tell us a lot
about jobs, about spending,
about how consumers are
doing, grocery, general goods.
How is Walmart doing?
And that's gonna tell us a lot
about how other retailers
are likely performing
throughout the economy and how
much consumers are spending
and going out there and buying.
And then also on Thursday we get Target.
We'll also get TJX, TJ Maxx,
Burlington, those companies.
They'll tell us about the kind
of budget-conscious consumer.
So we are gonna hear from all three
of those companies this week.
You're gonna wanna watch out for all those
for what they tell us about
the market, about consumers.
And I think the market, the
stock market, the bond market,
all those markets that we'll talk about
on "Market Takes" are gonna have
some major reactions depending
on how these come in.
So that sets us up, tomorrow
morning, 10:00 AM, be here
while we unpack the retail
sales report right here
on "Market Takes."
I'm your host, Dion Rabouin, reporter
at "The Wall Street Journal."
We hope to see you next time.